so people try to push this coach killer
narrative out of here but just talk to
me about what that Journey's been like
and what you're looking forward to it
Quinn Snyder okay this journey has been
tough I ain't had very many coaches
growing up I ain't really had too many
different Au coaches so like being
labeled a coach killer was crazy to me I
mean Lloyd coming in he was perfect for
us we came in together I got nothing but
love for LP with Nate like he had taken
over halfway through the year and he
wasn't even guaranteed to go further on
he didn't know how longer he would he
wanted to coach but we went to the
Eastern Conference Finals and we were
winning and he wanted to keep coaching
and keep coaching us and we were all
excited in doing that and we wanted to
keep rolling with him and then obviously
he he gets let go if he wanted to use me
again as a crutch for that for real like
we had a really good relationship to
begin with that's the only reason why he
stayed and stuck around hopefully Quinn
for me is my Steve Kerr like I hope
Quinn is the guy that we win three four
championships with that's my plan